[Musique]
bon ça joue très content d'être sur le
plateau de ses huit commença à partir ça
vous me faites peur chaque semaine oh là
là et je suis moi tu crois que je vais
me faire oublier par tous les bouts
folle ou de plus rigolo mais là tout
petit copain l'a prévenu que non mais
attends qu pas percé mais je vais faire
une liste d'attenté rappaz qu'est ce qui
se passe jamais à côté comme ça j'aime
bien c'est beau la coiffure est très
belle alors elle pas du tout tu sais que
toi on voit un pas tunisien pourquoi tu
es quelqu'un l'origine mais tu me dire
mais cabanon d'un très bonne qualité de
cheveux mais alors on peut je commence à
avoir des cheveux blancs c'est donc ça
c'est très problématique
mais là y'a une coiffeuse qui rêve
d'avoir les cheveux blancs voyait et à
une coiffeuse qui est en train de me
reprendre en main parce que là je trouve
que j'ai une coupe un peu de lieux enfin
j'adore jean pierre foucault mais j'ai
l'impression que je ressemble à jean
pierre foucault mais j'ai pas le même
âge donc ce n'est pas normal
donc là je suis sur une reprise en main
de ma coiffure donc là je vais faire des
petits dégradé tous avec franck intérêt
s'était parlé de ma coiffure je vous
réponds tu crois vraiment que ça
intéresse les gens
je vous dis qu'à une reprise en main et
s'intéresse dijon allez va libérer les
effets dans quelques semaines et tu vas
me dire pourquoi tu es venu alors je
suis venu j'ai compensé ces pourparlers
chiffon non mais c'est bon quoi ça vous
c'est vous qui me lancer sur mes cheveux
je vous réponds votes j'adore / est sûr
et ça lui sert et comment ça va nous
il se perd 2,8 du toubib côté jean luc
reichmann vous en faire d'autres vous
n'avez pas dit où l'équipe a dit
équeuter j'ai voulu dire de jonas tôt
bonjour chez nicolas sarkozy c'est
gérald dans la codacons a pas d'accord
je suis pas comme ça des bisous oui bah
ouais louisbourg connaît donc ça parce
que m division c'est le cas chez nous
c'est le seul à faire un petit dernier
pour les téléspectateurs qui voulait je
sais pas moi qui je sais faire encore
johnny de new line anthony je sais pas
alors c'est tout ce qui me fait rire
c'est très mal ils ont tout de suite de
deux minutes
si tu n'écoutes pas les autres préfèrent
toujours l'original à la copie
non donc sur elle cette semaine ce mec
j'ai interrogé le président emmanuel
macron c'est vrai oui j'ai prévenu macro
mais j'ai également surveiller les
coulisses de tpm p regardez bien un baba
très agité un gilles verdez très habité
seconde inside écrit ça non même pas
ouais c'est la fois fort salut à tous et
bienvenue dans 50 euros l'inside de pmp
et on commence tout de suite avec un
baba très très agitée cette semaine une
émission
oui on continue avec benjamin castaldi
qui met six à sept heures avons trouvé
une bonne
cette protégée
[Musique]
non et on continue avec lmh et novelli
qui boit les paroles d'isabelle morini
bosc
et on continue avec guillaume genton qui
visiblement a tous les talents
selon jules on va parler pression
atmosphérique qui aurait bien sûr par
les vêtements pour c'est drôle c'est une
obsession de vêtements chez lui j'ai
parlé comme ça qu'ils parlent jamais vu
les tragédies télévisuel mais la ratp
ne laissez jamais mais dans un coin à rb
à sa fenêtre et de mots caractérisent
gilles verdez bienveillance et honnêteté
dans le sud-ouest petit message codé
pour mon front eh bien on met un truc
dans le dos pour la redresser cette
annonce est un geste est superbe vidéo
et n'allez pas chercher la jeu de
benjamin castaldi et cyril sur wikipédia
je vous le donne quatre nuits
[Musique]
deepak physique merde il fait une petite
caste à dire bye toujours très captivés
par les interventions d abel et puis
surtout moi j'ai un immense regret
rigoler la france entière avec vous je
vous signale et aux parents d'isabelle
découvrez en exclu surtout le beau titre
mes poils de menthe et une les reverra
plus j'en ai fait les brosses celui 5
francs le kilo c'est du bon boulot pour
nourrir négoce et la phrase du radada
semaine est attribué à cyril hanouna ses
branches fait pas de cadeau parce que
j'ai pas envie que les gens m'aiment
parce que je leur fait des cadeaux gens
qui m'aiment pour ma personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et j'adore jay savan alla alain boursy
grande foule à louise à chérir génère ap
alors j'adore un monde tient très bien
ça c'est bien fait ça mais je viens
travailler tard à ses chiens
gilles verdez gilles verdez qui taille
surtout tous ses petits camarades
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal gilles
verdez le niveau est faible on voyait
alors mal rhône héros oui je les aime
beaucoup
on va dire je tiens à m'excuser merci
j'ai moi même avons dit pas je m'excuse
bien vouloir et alors ça c'est les
phrases 2.2 de paix aux militants
je m'excuse moment on ne dit pas je
m'excuse je te prie de bien vouloir
m'excuser parce que je m'excuse ça
voudrait dire que tu t'excuses ses bons
voeux de bienvenue bien et après quelque
chose pas si la semaine dernière on a
beaucoup ri sur un magnéto mais vous
avez critiqué une personne en
particulier
et ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine séguin
mon cul
[Rires]
cette laitue l'a vu mockus est vrai que
ça a contaminé a le petit jeu est très
fort avec benjamin et céline faye a
contaminé un peu tout le monde tous les
chroniqueurs s'y sont essayés cette
semaine alors en fout on à la champion's
league et bien dans tes pmp on à la
champion's slip
[Applaudissements]
mon cul tu apparu toi
[Musique]
lui a encore une polémique sur le papier
au cul
j'ai perdu mon truc tu regardes quoi et
on verra plus jamais je ne ferais que
les accords
j'ai failli condamner à lemoine qui la
met en danger mais russell quitté moi je
signe à sion ouest a annoncé par la
suite un genre vbg revivre
[ __ ] vous arrêtez avec votre cul
l'interview j'en peux plus je joue plus
attentifs
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le plus beau but de la turquie pour la
diffuser la semaine dernière c'est le tu
l'as vu beaucoup de divisions scolaires
vu mon q bat excusé vote excusé au elle
adhère pas du tout et tuba budo castaldi
l'essai ils n'ont ils essayent très
souvent effectivement non mais c'est
bien comme il de répétition ça
fonctionne mais moi c'est sa petite
danse incroyable j'étais gentil j'ai
envie de faire à tu l'as vu mon cul à ma
mère ça rigolait alors elle va me
défoncer allez on y va je l'appelle
maman
j'appelle ma mère bah allez vous faire
engueuler non mais en plus ça c'est pas
con à l'antenne ouais ouais ouais donc
ça va être crédible parce qu'elle est en
train de faire des à manger là près par
l'univers effet dû me choki ims uk
oui c'est vrai qu'avec des galettes
respecte ça fait du foot mais dites donc
ça fait péter ça je me souviens pas mais
toi tu vas voir ça va ça va péter ta
gueule aussi
ma mère me répond pas à aller belle la
france n'a plus jamais retrouvé
je serre les mains vertes à mais en même
temps on va essayer de faire à tulle a
vu à travers moi madame r c'est moi
c'est le répondeur de ma mère voilà va
me rappeler j'espère va dia tu peux te
manier oui j'appelle aussi admirer fort
ma mère a cuisiné pour ce soir vous
croyez quoi calme-toi quelle autre ouais
moment comment ça va ah ouais super dis
moi ce soir et ce soit arrivé à manger
mais mais mais mais demain dimanche que
tu
tu sais que tu sais qui vient manger
mais je vais ramener un invité un invité
spécial
mon cul bon bah ce soir madame elle base
madame haman merci mais non merci on est
désolés vous livrer et tu fais de gros
bisous et vous l'embrassez aussi
d'accord vous l'embrassez vous
l'embrassez immense et de ma part mais
oui a tellement apprécié du rappel mais
après quatre ans qu'il en fait c'est
quoi
généralement quand à mr denis chasse et
qui a reçu le bulletin
largué à l'est pas bon c'est pas sa
maman je travaille a pris un gros coup
de pression par ta mère je suis pas
stérile
alors vous savez qu'on ne cesse de vous
le répéter toutes les semaines vous avez
toutes les qualités
animateur producteur danseurs chanteurs
toute personne va mettre dans l'agora du
tout mais pas du tout pas du tout ça du
tout toutes les qualités qui finit sans
heurts mais vous avez ce petit truc que
les autres animateurs n'ont pas bientôt
c'est quoi jaubert alors qu'est-ce qu'il
ad'autres g où j'ai un dernier magnéto
sur vous cyril parce que vous êtes ça et
c'est quoi votre principale qualité
tu es très sympa avec leur semble des
personnes il s'y prête
et oui mais vous avez une autre qualité
c'est que vous êtes un petit arbre avec
vos chroniqueurs mais sa tête juste
essayé d'appeler ma mère a beau essayer
de faire
voilà quand même ce ce tu l'as vu ce qui
s'est bien que ma mère répondent pas
quand même je comprends pas je très
inquiet j'ai très inquiet est-ce que ça
va marcher
bizarre mais j'ai envie de réparer ses
auditoires à tétouan et l'occupé à l'eau
oui ma oui mais bon ça va c'est vrai que
tu fais j'ai bien mangé
adacore m'a dit moi il est venue ou pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
autant brasse m'at on en plateau j'avais
tissu union oui bien sur des bases
saines et y suit non avec vous deux
dernières petites choses
elle est sûre vous en syrie parce que
c'est vrai que toutes les semaines alors
vous êtes quelqu'un de très gentil mais
vous avez une tendance fâcheuse une
fâcheuse tendance
je sais mieux quand on se fâche sur une
tendance fâcheuse à casser un petit peu
avec guy
[Musique]
alors qu un [ __ ] jours à gagner ici je
te dois les suceurs genre mais c'est
vrai que les infirmiers mais ferme ta
gueule tu veux pécho tu dis laury
thilleman le rapport à des coûts est là
parce que ta soeur de gouvernementale
suceurs de mista se sort de tout ça tu
mesures à mettre deux postulats fort
boyard connard tu l'as acheté ça non
mais sans rigoler c'est pas toi t'en
type génial respecte toi tu mérites plus
le bordel je dormais c'est vrai quoi
j'ai une révélation qu'est ce qu'il est
beau castaldi et c'est là que mon père
qui est médecin appeler son copain
ophtalmo qu'il a reprises qu'il a prises
en urgence eu les couilles mais je
t'adore mechmont pas les couilles mais
total en fait ça va déchirer
c'est génial ses missions et vendredi
faute derrière vous êtes payés
[Rires]
à droite ou à gauche est tous les
vendredis plaisir à libérer